We won't be doing that today.
Tomorrow.
tomorrow works.
Think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can save today.
But you can save the world.
Steve?
Diana?
You know what you need to do.
Nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
Ah that's just a trashcan. It's just a trash
can.
Yeah yeah
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer preview breakdown
they just dropped a bunch of new images
we have our first look at what cheetah
actually looks like during the movie so
we'll break it all down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're also doing a movie
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post your
favorite Wonder Woman Theory in the
comments I'll name a new winner at the
end of this so we'll just break this
down top 10 WTF style starting with
number 10 Maxwell Lord and cheetah
staring at this Black Rock object on his
desk
this is the real MacGuffin of the movie
it explains everything about what's
going on with Steve Trevor coming back
to life you know everything goes
completely crazy in the movie as the
earlier trailer in previews implied
cheetah in the movie played by Kristen
Wiig starts out as Barbara Minerva and
archaeologist working at the Museum they
give her a bit of an origin story during
the movie but she's just meant to be
this awkward normal funny scientist when
we meet her at the beginning of the film
number 9 of course Wonder Woman also
works at the Museum so they're kind of
keeping continuity with the first Wonder
Woman film Batman vs Superman and all
the stuff that they set up previously so
this is still in keeping with the
Justice League timeline even though
they've retcons some things about her
backstory we started working at the
Louvre in the previous movies in
present-day
Wonder Woman 1984 obviously takes place
during the 80s as the title implies so
apparently she just worked at the Museum
in Washington DC during the 80s before
going to work at the Louvre the Black
Rock passes through the museum so that's
where it sort of enters the plot and
that's how they encounter it because
they're both working at the Museum
number 8 WTF Maxwell Lord is apparently
not a telepath like most people probably
know him from the more recent comic book
stories he's obviously the main villain
of the film but it was a big question
about what his powers would be Pedro
Pascal and patty Jenkins explained that
what's going on with him at the
beginning of the movie is that he's
actually closer to the original version
of comic book Maxwell Lord from Justice
League International when he was first
introduced in the comics that version
was more of a parody of your typical 80s
yuppie businessman like Patrick Bateman
from American Psycho he starts the movie
as a failing oil man and TV salesman
with a company that's going bankrupt and
he's losing investors part of the reason
patty Jenkins said she set the movie
during the eighties specifically is
because it was such a period of excess
and greed
you see all that through his character
through the film he wants it all money
fame respect you kind of get that vibe
from him at all the infomercials you see
plain during the trailer so number seven
the connection between Maxwell Lord and
cheetah because you see them a lot
during these preview pictures in the
trailer footage is that he learns about
the special rock and thinks that it will
give him power to make all of his wishes
and desires a reality but cheetah or
Barbara Minerva have you want to think
about her doesn't start out being a
villain she's just this normal person
she's meant to be sort of a tragic
villain in the sense that she's a good
person at the beginning of the movie
who's corrupted by greed and Maxwell
Lord remember the whole theme of the
movie is about what greed does to people
turns you into a metaphorical monster
and obviously because it's a comic book
movie eventually a literal monster
number six what is this rock and why is
it so special why is Maxwell Lord
cradling it so much during the trailer
footage I don't think this is meant to
be anything specific from a comic book
story but it functions kind of like the
Dragon Balls if you're a big Dragon Ball Z
fan I wouldn't say super Dragon Balls
it's not that powerful like you couldn't
alter the universe with it but imagine
Maxwell Lord can use it to grant
people's wishes so that kind of explains
what's going on with Maxwell Lords rise
to power and Steve Trevor during the
movie the movie kind of continues to
world build in the DC Universe with more
magical artifacts that you see during
the trailers like she's wearing her
special golden winged battle armor from
the comics what makes the wings work
well it's kind of enchanted with God
level magic I know there's a lot of you
DC Magic fans that are hoping that they
eventually make a Justice League dark
movie at some point with a bunch of
magic characters Wonder Woman in Shazam
Black Adam movies are kind of the
beginning of that magic based stories
inside the DC Universe number five WTF
so what's the deal with Steve Trevor
there been so many theories about this
but based on the way they explained the
MacGuffin the special black rock patty
Jenkins isn't lying or misleading people
when she says this is really Steve
Trevor he's alive and well during the
movie it's not secretly someone else
pretending to be his Steve Trevor and
he's not some glorious fanny-pack
figment of her imagination he's real
walking around and getting confused
about trash in art nope that's just
trash so based on what Chris Pine patty
Jenkins the other actors are saying
Steve Trevor's return is connected to
Maxwell Lord in the special Black Rock
Dragon Ball if it were possible for
Wonder Woman
to be greedy what would she want well
she wouldn't want to be sad about Steve
Trevor anymore she would want him back
number four what is the real conflict of
the movie well based on the footage and
what Pedro Pascal is saying about his
villain Arg is the whole idea that the
Dragon Ball concept gets way out of
control and it turns into this big
potential global threat it is part of
their whole statement on what gree can
do to destroy people when he has that
line of dialogue in the trailer saying
now I take what I want in return he's
speaking literally apparently like it
has something to do with the mechanics
of how this black rock works he takes
something from people when he grants
them their deepest darkest desire number
three Wonder Woman versus cheetah
obviously longtime rivals in the comics
cheetah probably one of her most
infamous comic book villains but in the
movie she's meant to be a tragic
character metaphorically turned into a
monster by Creed and Maxwell Lords
message is implied by the trailer
literally then turned into a monster by
the big final battle because this is a
comic book movie she actually has to
show up as cheetah in the movie at some
point so logically that just plays into
the themes of what's going on this is
actually a recent promo picture from
some merchandising material so I don't
know if this is what she will actually
look like when she becomes comic book
cheetah the design of the picture looks
like it's right out of the 1980s but it
might just be a partial form
they've been tweaking the movie for a
long time now and editing in
post-production so I'm assuming that
this will look a little bit different
during the final version of the film
number 2 the golden armor so yeah it
looks super badass in the trailer it's
implied that she needs this because of
what's going on during the big final
battle to protect her from cheetahs
attacks when she gets her crazy comic
book abilities it looks like she's in
the middle of some big fight here when
she's wearing it in the trailer the
wings come off so maybe cheetah just
starts ripping the armor to shreds when
she gets her claws I think part of the
idea of a fight like this though is that
even if cheetah becomes more powerful
than Wonder Woman just in terms of power
scaling the Wonder Woman is still a much
better fighter much better tactician in
early prediction that's probably how
she'll wind up beating cheetah
some clever twists like yes you could
wish to be as strong as you want but
you're never going to be a smarter fighter
than me a lot of people forget just
because Wonder Woman is so powerful that
she's actually been training to fight
for so long fight in so many battles
she's a way better tactician and smarter
fighter than pretty much everybody else
in the number one obviously what
the Wonder Woman sequels Wonder Woman
three patty Jenkins and gal gadot have
already said that they're going to make
Wonder Woman three but they're not
thinking about doing it is another
period piece set during the past so it
implies that Wonder Woman three will
take place at least somewhere near
present day providing a lot more
opportunities for crossover with other
big characters really good example
recently right after Aquaman came out
Jason Momoa was talking about Aquaman
two he's like I would love to have
Wonder Woman in Aquaman 2 but that movie
isn't coming out till 2022 so if Wonder
Woman does cross over into other movies
in present day we won't find out about
for a while some of the future DC movies
will continue to be connected to the
original Justice League timeline the one
movie I think that's going to fix some of
their minor continuity issues because of
the way they're treating their new films
is the flash flashpoint movie as
everybody would expect they did say it'd
be a very different type of flashpoint
from comic book flashpoint but is the
same basic concept the flash totally
derps the timeline and it changes a few
things and then they use that to sort of
fix their DC timeline of movies and even
though it's still a long ways off people
like Zachary Levi obviously playing the
Shazam character has said that the idea
is that he would eventually join the
Justice League in the next Justice
League movie when that does wind up
happening but it's probably going to be
several years he was also one of the
people who was like I would love to have
Wonder Woman in one of the Shazam
sequels
so maybe cameo from Wonder Woman in
Shazam 2 or Shazam 3 they're actually
getting ready to shoot Shazam 2 and the
Black Adam movie simultaneously this
summer do you smell what The Rock Black
Adam is cooking but everyone post all
your Wonder Woman theories in the
comments below what do you want them to
do with her character next who do you
want her to crossover with in present
day I will do a new Black Adam video
sometime soon they've been talking more
and more about just a society in that
movie so it sounds like it's going to be
really cool but congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last DC video
mystery solved please email me on the
about page of my channel on the desktop
website so I can get your details
everyone click here for that new Joker
deleted scene and alternate ending video
and click here for the Batman Teaser Trailer
video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome
This is the way.